581 with more than 120 million eligible
voters the election commission of
Pakistan can take up to two weeks to
declare a winner but that time may not
be
necessary this man Nazar Sharif and his
Pakistan Muslim League party will likely
come out on top he's been prime minister
three times previously his main
Challenger is otherwise occupied Imran
KH is serving jail time for corruption
and breach of National Security but he
is still wildly popular share was also
kicked out of office and convicted of
corruption but he had his record cleared
enabling him to run
again I've been casting votes in
elections since 1970 says this man he
likes the older days better saying
families now struggle to pay their bills
and buy
food Pakistan is in an economic crisis
and is struggling with militant violence
on Wednesday there were two separate
strikes outside political party campaign
offices killing at least 22 people
fearing what would happen election day
the UN Human Rights Chief appealed to
authorities to ensure a free and fair
vote citing incidents of terrorism the
interior Ministry cut cell service for
the day critics said he was a way for
the caretaker government and indirectly
the military to influence the election
audio and video messages are popular as
the nation has low literacy
rates it's part of the reason Pakistan
allows parties to use symbols for voters
to recognize their candidates well we
don't know the outcome yet in the past
75 years no prime minister has served
their full five-year term Crystal ganing
Global News London